benjamin castaldi qui a hérité du nom de
son père mais pas forcément des talents
de fond père je le trouve un petit peu
aigri un petit peu colérique lorsqu'il
dit qu'il ne voudra plus me serrer la
main et bien écoute en pis il me servira
plus la main ça nous fera des vacances
d'autant que c'est pas lui qui me donne
à manger
et puis il faut quand même qu'il se
rappelle qu'il a été repêché par anodin
sinon il serait peut-être dans l'oublié
dans l'abandon en fait j'ai droit à sa
salle
non mais alors pourquoi toute cette
histoire et parce qu'en fait ils étaient
ils étaient invités n'a été dit l'était
il était invité n'en avons été invités
je crois avec cyril il était déprogrammé
3 qui l'a mal vécu de ne pas être avec
celle et d'être avec moi et c'est donc
on a bien reçu ici alors que je n'avais
pas pourquoi je propose qu'on l'appelle
[Applaudissements]
chevalet
sabbatique jeudi dans sa catégorie à
witham l on va l'appeler pas suivre mon
tiercé mais au nom d'omar sans répondre
il avait deux façons en paix bonjour
monsieur bonjour monsieur je m'appelle
benjamin castaldi
vous êtes donc le bébert des forbans
j'ai appris récemment dans une vidéo que
vous m'aimez pas tellement j'étais pas
pourquoi donc n'hésitez pas à me
rappeler je suis en direct sur ces 8 la
chaîne qui grimpe dans les avions
toujours à mon poste les petits qui
relate ce qui gratte
n'hésitez pas à me rappeler que je pars
conso part parce que vous êtes venus ici
vous été bien reçue il à vous mettez des
attaques et du matin au soir
ça commence à me gonfler
[Applaudissements]
au début il me connaissait on va aller
déjà laissé des messages moi c'était
parce qu'on a